The general can experience or gyms open out here. Yes. Okay. Yeah.
You can work it out. You definitely can't. You haven't been to digital in LA.
Haven't been able to work out in since the original thing.
It's going to be over a year. They're going to,
they're treating everybody like babies. This is what it is, man.
They're treating everybody like you're not allowed to make your own decisions,
including business owners that have spent a ton of money opening up these
outdoor cafes and outdoor restaurants.
And then they don't even supply any science. There's there's not even,
they're essentially autocrats, right? They're a dictator.
They come and they tell you what they're gonna close with.
They're not going to close. They don't have to show.
There's an overwhelming body of evidence that shows that all this is spreading
from yoga studios. We have to stop yoga. Right.
And even then it'd be like, okay, inside. Yoga's bad.
But what about park yoga? Is that okay? Is it okay to do parking lot yoga?
I think there's just no data.
So you have these people that are idiots. They're so dumb.
They keep getting busted going on vacation when they're telling everybody to
stay home. Yeah.
The mayor of Austin told people it's not time to relax while he was in
Cabo. Crazy.
That is to go to Cabo and be in a condo in Cabo and go, listen,
we can't relax. Like don't travel. Stay away from people. All right. Take care.
Shuts off assault. Dat dat, dat they're partying.
Gavin Newsome.
He didn't dinner at a fancy restaurant in Napa with his friends.
No social distancing, no masks.
Right on top of each other doors closed in doors. There's a roof.
There's a door shut. There's a glass window. I mean,
maybe there was like a part of that door where you could open up and you can go
outside. That's not an endorsed or that's not outdoors.
Outdoors is no roof over your head.
You don't have a chandelier outdoors, outdoors.
Did you see sky? That's outdoors? You.
You can't have a roof and chandelier and say, I'm eating outdoors.
That's a lie. You're lying. But look out the window, bro.
The mayor of Chicago, same thing gets bused to getting their haircut.
These people are gross. They're gross.
They keep getting busted doing the things they're trying to tell people not to
do. And I don't know why they don't think they're going to get caught.
They keep getting caught. And it's, it's crazy that you,
I don't understand it. I don't understand it. I, I,
there's gotta be a better way to do this.
That allows people to keep their businesses, keep their businesses open,
stay healthy, go out.
I eat 100% of my meals out. I have a weird,
you know, lifestyle. I don't eat at home. Um, and
we made friends with some of these people these past few months, you know,
I found some new restaurants and things like that.
And once you make friends with them and you talk to them a bit,
you end up, they end up sharing with you like, Oh yeah, this, but we're,
you know, we're really struggling. We're on our last leg.
My father who's owned arrest who owned a restaurant for 30 years.
Closed it in June.
It's already some other like corporate janky.
Someone tagged me in a picture. Yeah. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
Closed this Italian restaurant restaurant for almost 30 years.
It was his entire life.
He would hang out with people at the bar until at his bar until,
you know, one, two, 3:00 AM. And he would start, uh,
making the sauce and stuff at five or six,
he would sleep for a couple of few hours and then start another day of his
entire everything was that. Um,
and I, I hope to check on him, see how he's doing. But uh,
but I can't imagine him doing anything else.
I always assumed he was going to do that absolutely forever. But this is,
this is the story for almost all restaurant owners, man.
They just don't have that.
They're more like comedians or artists or something like they spend the money
that they make. You know, it's sort of just a different,
you take care of so many people you sorta want to be taken care of.
So they like vacationing and they liked doing this and they liked doing that.
So, so many of them, and it costs a lot of money.
And for a lot of restaurant owners, it almost is like an art form. Like,
or almost like a source of entertainment too,
because you're not just providing a delicious meal.
You're also giving them a nice environment. You're welcoming them.
It's hospitality is a big part of it.
So many of these places, you know,
we found this one place driving around one night. Um, we drove by this,
uh, Italian restaurant. We were starving and like everything was closed, close,
close, close, close. It was like a Wednesday at nine. Right? We were,
it was a long shot. We drove by this one place and we ended up the kid worked.
There was the grandson, the grandfather's the owner,
the grandma's inside answering the phone, unloading wine or whatever.
Like you would see her if you use the restroom. My point is like they were,
they had, he was honest, you know, he was just, they're just open people again.
We bought these heat lamps. Uh, you know, this is crazy.
What do we have to do? It's like an app. It was an alleyway.
And I know for a fact, even though we didn't say it, that there, they weren't,
they just, weren't having a good year to say the least. Um,
and uh,
and it's just frightening to think that all these places with all these good
people in LA,
aren't going to have a chance that opening up after they spend money on the heat
lamps, after they completely reorganized their entire structure.
I see.
Has there been any big cities that decided to just try to stay open
most of the pandemic? I don't think so. Right.
I don't think there's any big cities that are run by Republicans. Are there.
Uh, big cities run by Republicans?
They just left everything open.
Basically. I mean like mayors. Yeah.
Like what about Miami? Just Googling me. I was like.
Miami might be Miami. I think Miami,
I think Florida as a whole, the governor of Florida has basically said, listen,
the cure can't be worse than the disease. And it's killing our businesses.
It's killing our people. It's like a lot of people are committing suicide.
A lot of people are getting addicted to drugs and you know,
and he took a pragmatic approach and you could disagree or, or agree.
And a lot of people disagree and I understand it. There,
there is an issue though that a lot of people who disagree with him,
being able to him being able to do this and opening things up there,
they're financially capable of surviving a year or even
longer without work. And many of them are actually in the middle of work.
And, uh, I don't want to cast any aspersions. I don't want to cast any blame.
I don't know. I don't want to point any fingers.
That's not what I'm trying to do.
But what I want to say is that it's really difficult
to even imagine. And this is coming from someone who doesn't have to imagine it.
So I know how ridiculous this sounds,
but it's difficult to imagine the mindset of someone who's losing
everything. If you're not losing anything, if your life is basically the same,
and this is the problem with some of the politicians, they,
they didn't get punished financially for their cities shutting down.
They didn't get punished financially for 40% of the businesses going under.
I mean, sure, it's going to be tough for them to get reelected,
but they can say, listen, we were in a pandemic. We did, we could,
we saved lives. That'll be, that'll be the propaganda.
That'll be what they put the pitch that they saved lives by doing this.
But they don't,
they don't act the way a person would act if their
entire life's work was on the line,
like your dad and his restaurant,
they don't act like that person where they find a way to keep things open and
keep things reasonably safe, where they find a way, look, there's a,
there's a better solution here.
What we've got to do is like keep people healthier and that'll lower the numbers
of cases. And that will also lower the severity of cases.
And that allow us to open places up to a reasonable extent. You know,
how about we do this? How about we do that? How about,
is there a better way to protect people than handkerchiefs?
Like what's better handkerchiefs and 95 masks. Can we just get everybody?
And then 95 mask, it seems like that's a better way to go. Those things.
Like nothing gets through those, but handkerchiefs, he could blow.
You ever see demonstrations,
people do with a handkerchief and a mask as a mask rather. And they,
they let a lighter and go and blow the lighter out.
And then they do the same thing with like a cloth mask, little more difficult.
Then they go to an N 95 mask and nothing happens, nothing. It doesn't get out.
So that thing acts as Soho's hopefully some sort of a filter to keep
most of the viral load or whatever. I don't I'm, I don't know.
I don't know how it works, but when you look at the effectiveness of that mask,
let's say that if everybody had an awareness of 95 mask,
it cut infections down X amount percent. Let's do that. Let's do that.
And if you, if you're talking about Corona virus, like in LA,
there were saying 3%. I think it was three point.
1% was coming from restaurants would, if those people were wearing N 95 masks,
would that drop that 3.1 down to nothing?
Would it be one like is one acceptable where people can keep their living?
Like you got to look at these people. You got, first of all, you got to look.
Government's never been able to tell you, you can't work. This is unprecedented.
This is completely new.
Government has never been able to tell like everyone in an industry
I'm in the indoor dining industry, everyone in your industry can't work.
Government has never had that kind of power. Government has never,
ever in the history of the United States of America had the power to shuttle the
gyms down. So you can't say, Hey,
all you healthy studs and stud debts and stud exes. You,
you, you can't go work out. It's not up to you.
It's not the people who own that business. Sorry.
I know you've worked your whole life.
Maybe you did construction for 15 years and saved up half your pay and put it
all away with this dream of one day,
opening of this amazing gym and making your living off your own business.
You created yourself in the community that you live in, but no, no,
the government knows better than you.
And they get to decide whether or not you can work.
They get to decide whether or not you take chances,
whether or not you feel like you've adequately protected yourself from the
virus, whether you test enough, they get to this.
And a curfew, the psychological effect of knowing. And by the way,
they're not enforcing it. They're not cops. Aren't pulling you over and going,
what are you doing?
But they don't need to the fact that you know that you're supposed to have a 10,
10:00 PM.
Dude, you know what they should do. They should have a,
a loud siren that plays throughout the city at 10,
just to freak you out. Like war of world style.
[inaudible] imagine tornado sirens in Ohio, where they have that. I could just,
just like that, like a tornado siren.
We went from Texas back to California. It was like, uh,
being on vacation and then going to boarding school psychologically.
It was like that it didn't, you know, there was no one enforcing the rules.
Boarding school. It's more like juvenile detention. Yeah. Yeah. You're,
you're not, you're going to a book.
Except juvenile detention. At least they feed you more.
Then you with a bunch of other ups, you get to have a good time. Yeah.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.